[Musik]
halo hat sich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen leckeren und
saftigen schokoladenkuchen meine jungs
im büro die haben sich einen guinness
kuchen gewünschten ist das essen
schwarzbier ich werde es ist heute aber
als unfall machen mit wie damals das
heißt ihr könnt dann von sich selbst
entscheiden was sie nehmen möchte
entweder ging es mit alkohol oder das x
pire dann nehme ich jetzt das wie damals
weil es einfach geschmacklich eben
hinkommt und daraus werde ich dann eine
schöne frühlings oster torte zaubern
ich verwende dafür 250 gramm butter 250
gramm zucker 250 gramm guinness oder
malz 43 eier etwas vanille extrakt 250
gramm mehl 100 gramm kakaopulver eine
prise salz zwei teelöffel backpulver und
einen halben teelöffel natron und 150
gramm joghurt da nehme ich es den
dreieinhalb prozentigen jetzt nämlich
zuerst die butter die kommt in dem job
von wird geschmolzen direkte zucker mit
dazugeben und ich kann ihnen da
zwischenzeit schon mal die eier
verrühren
da klebt ihr schon mal dass vanille
extrakt dazu das rezept ist echt super
einfach da gucken wird immer saftig und
erhält auch normalerweise vier bis fünf
tage aber bei uns sind superschnell
ausgelassen feiere und von elektra kurz
berühren so dass sie schön schaumig sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bei der butter 80 im prinzip nur darauf
dass sie mich zu heiß wird also nicht
kochen lassen sondern wirklich nur so
lange bis sie schwitzt das kühle ich
jetzt hier kurz ab mit dem malzbier da
kann ich nämlich gleich
weiterverarbeiten und ihm die eier
mischung rhein geben wenn es zu heiß ist
geringen im studio bin jetzt einfach
kurz einrühren
die sich aus dem kleines küken naja ich
glaube für dich nach oster torte backen
braten müsste ich also weiterhin spaß
hier arbeiten ich arbeite auch so
stoffel bringe ich euch raus dann habe
ich hier die trockenen zutaten mehl kato
backpulver salz und natron bereits
vermischt die werden jetzt gesiebt so
verschwinden nämlich die klümpchen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt nur auf der joghurt mit
dazu und alle zutaten werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
derzeit ist relativ flüssig daher werde
ich jetzt den tortenring einfach mit
backpapier einschlagen damit nicht auf
[Applaus]
dann einfach schön verteilen und ich
ziehe den am rand immer so ein bisschen
hoch so packt dann noch gleichmäßiger
und dann kommen das scheinbar gucken
[Musik]
jetzt kann der schokoladenkuchen
dekoriert werden
ich habe jetzt hier kuvertüre 200 gramm
zart witter und habe die bereits gehackt
und den zwei drittel ein drittel
eingeteilt deswegen damit ich jetzt mit
kuvertüre gleich temperieren kann und
das muss ich machen damit sie später
schön fest bleibt im glanz hat und
keinen grauschleier bekommt und dann
nehme ich einfach immer mit teekanne von
roma macht da einfach im wasserbad mit
einem kleinen schälchen jetzt kommen
hier zuerst die zwei drittel rein und
das wasser habe ich kochen lassen um den
herd wieder ausgemacht und so kann ich
einfach sicherstellen dass eben auch
kein wasser in der schokolade landet
soll einfach nicht zu heiß sein wird sie
zwei drittel hier rein kurz schmelzen
lassen und das restliche drittel hebe
ich mir dann auch zum herunterkühlen
jetzt ist die schokolade geschmolzen
und jetzt kommt hier das übrige drittel
rein und damit wird die kuvertüre
heruntergekühlt jetzt hat sie etwa 50
grad und durch die übrige kuvertüre
kommt irgendwie für 30 grad
[Musik]
so sieht sie jetzt perfekt aus und jetzt
fühle ich sehe in einem spritzbeutel ihr
könnt auch eine gefriertruhe nehme aber
aufpassen dass die nicht reißt einfach
oben verschließen
jetzt wird daraus ein lässt gespritzt
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier schon
wasser vorbereitet eiskaltes wasser ich
hatte dort kurz im gefrierschrank
eiswürfel sind auch drin
und wer möchte kann sogar noch eine
prise salz dazugeben
deshalb sorgt nämlich dafür dass das
wasser noch kälter wird dann geht es
einem spritzbeutel hier mit kleiner
spitze wegschneiden je größer ihr weg
schreitet umso dicker wird das nest also
da werden die einzelnen stränge einfach
deswegen lieber klein anfangen
jetzt habe ich ja hier meinen kuchen und
der hat einen durchmesser von 24 cm und
das nest soll einfach ein bisschen
kleiner werden
bin jetzt hier greife die schokolade ins
wasser spritzen
[Musik]
da haben auch gern bisschen runter
drücken und durch das eiswasser wird die
schokolade gleich fest und ich kann es
dreidimensionaler gestalten
und ich lasse jetzt immer eine schicht
kurz fest werden drückst leicht runter
und dann kommt die nächste schicht oben
drauf also immer nur ganz kurz warten
und dann insgesamt für eine minute mal
im wasser lassen damit die schokolade
festwirt bevor ich sage aufnehmen kann
vorsichtig herauslösen
so mache ich mir jetzt noch mal so ein
kleineres lässt für ihnen rein und dann
wird's richtig schön
[Musik]
das sieht nicht gut aus gefällt mir sehr
gut und vor allem ist es eine mega
einfache technik sie kann jeder zu hause
machen
ich stelle jetzt das nest kurz in den
kühlschrank damit einfach die schokolade
noch mal schön fest werden kann
vor allem das auch das wasser noch ab
tropft und in derzeit hole ich schon mal
kleine süße eier und die werden jetzt
auch noch ganz schnell und richtig
einfach dekorieren der kuchen ist jetzt
abgekühlt ich habe jetzt hier in einem
haus lebt ein bischen reis linsen könnt
ihr auch nehmen denn ich nehme noch
etwas kakao und damit einfach nicht zu
viel rauskommt macht man das einfach
hier mit dem rhein so damit in den see
ist auch eine schöne matte oberfläche
müsst ihr nicht aber ich finde es ganz
hübsch und da setze ich jetzt das nest
drauf
und die eier kommen die mitte jetzt habe
ich hier kinder überraschungseier und
dieses smart easy pack ich mal aus ich
glaube wenn die jungs und zampella
wissen was da drin steckt dann freuen
sie sich noch mehr also nicht nur über
den schokokuchen sondern auch über den
überraschung
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr sie noch
mit etwas bronze metallisch grün oder
einfach direktor einlegen
setzt sich die hier einst last
und jetzt können wir probieren
[Musik]
ihr dürft jetzt probieren genehmigt der
monaten probiert jetzt tempora probiert
ich habe hier einen guinness kochen
alkoholfrei
ich habe nämlich mehr wie damals und es
ist jetzt ein schokokuchen ich habe mir
gedacht das wäre der perfekte ort für
männer ich meine gerade vorteilhaft aus
natürlich haben gerade eingebaut und
grüßen möchte doris julia ist die
tochter von jetzt begrüßen die schöne
julia und ich hab dann die ein stück
kuchen mehr habt mir ein paradiesgarten
häuschen gebaut und war super ich schaue
mir gleich an zwei linke hände und zwar
für jeden berg zu kommen
falls ja zwei werkzeugkoffer für jeden
auf jetzt rasch was ausgesät so was hab
ich gesehen
man muss auch sagen der kuchen
angeschnitten super aus anschneiden ist
natürlich ein problem
ja ich hab ich nämlich die eier kurz
unternehmens und das nest es wird
natürlich zerstört werden aber ich mein
zuhause halten hingucker die alpha essen
jahrzehnt hinter überraschungs ei und
marty seyer auf gold angesprüht weil das
atelier und jetzt am besten entweder
nehmen dieses netz herunter oder ihr
macht so wie ich ihr könnt aber das
messer erhitzen
[Musik]
ist auch so einen der ihren top
bibelgarten häuser sowie sie traten als
privat bleibt privat funktion motorräder
roller gaszähler cool aus ich schneide
ich jetzt ein stück an können wir dann
zusammen probieren ich finde der
abschnitt mega das kann ich auf dem
helfen durchschneiden hat jeder was auf
dem teller mit der gabel danach zu sagen
was geht also gesagt hat wir so einfach
das gehört also gesagt ja ich habe
gehört du hast mehr gearbeitet
vielmehr gewesen schließlich auch arbeit
und der kuchen der wird von tag zu tag
besser als er könnte den einpacken und
der wird von tag zu tag aromatischer und
sagt finger lassen richtig richtig coole
schoko bomben und nach egal
das glaubt ist schokolade hätte ich habe
überall rwe und aber es können ja
schokoladen m war ehrlich ganz cool ich
finde genau das finde ich auch sehr gut
dass der kuchen einfach nicht so süß ist
ich habe auch einige guinness rezepte
durchgeforstet und ich habe überall
ungefähr die hälfte lassen also wirklich
den kuchen das ist ja auch ein irischer
kuchen und daneben die extrem viel
zucker aber ich habe einfach den zucker
reduziert so finde ich nicht gut das ist
alkoholfrei war ja man kann es auch okay
das rezept gibt es auch sallys blog.de
macht doch gerne nach das ist wirklich
eine super einfache torte und einfacher
kuchen zu ostern oder auch einfach mal
so wenn ihr und saftig ein
schokoladenkuchen haben und haben viel
spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
liebe grüße nach
[Musik]